so you heard two pieces taken out of
context which is something I usually
don't like to do at all
but for this purpose I think the
composers would have agreed that it is a
good idea because if we talk about
something we need to know what we talked
about and I picked these two
compositions the two composers
to show how on with complete with a
complete different set of tools the same
impact within the listener can be
reached so I assume that most
musicologist would agree that bass
composition is more complex more
sophisticated in the counterpoint then
Vivaldi's composition the vidas turbot
mod has a pretty simple composition
harmonically yet both compositions
achieve to me when I sing and I think
also to the audience they can achieve a
deep spiritual experience or a moving
experience so we cannot say that the
more complex the composition is the
better it is
some people are moved by compositions by
Andrew Lloyd Webber and and I don't want
to want to joke about it just recently
we heard a concert of a friend and this
girl just started singing promise me and
the lady next to me burst into tears so
and I for a fraction of a second I
thought is they silly why is she but no
after mili second I realized no how can
I judge what is moving what is honest
what is truthful and so bath and Vivaldi
here of course I thought a lot what is
how can we describe truth in in music
and what I just realized
to just go back in time now about 45
minutes when we rehearsed this piece
here I was just upstairs having a coffee
still discussing with robb while the
orchestra already started playing the
first move
of this [ __ ] hard 170 and I just didn't
rush but I walked down quickly and I
stood in place and had to sing the piece
out of nowhere and out of context as I
said before and the difficulty of course
is to get into the mood but then I
realized that if we want to achieve
something that is truthful that is
honest it doesn't come through me alone
it's the collective effort that creates
a moment of truth in concert so to
succeed in conveying the message of the
composer it's not the composition alone
of course most important it's the
composer but it's the musicians and it's
every individual musician that really
needs to feel the deep desire to give
everything and when I stood there in the
rehearsal
I just turned around and I saw all these
musicians everybody was so much into it
and it made me so happy and I thought
this is where this where the great
moments on stage come from it's the
collective effort a concert will only be
perceived by the audience as a
fulfilling experience if really
everybody in the within the group wants
to achieve this and I've unfortunately
of course I've also played in Orchestra
as well as 70 percent' motivated players
and 30% players who do their duty which
they call in Germany I made some Dienst
and there yeah Limits Orchestra
musicians who grabbed their violin as
somebody grabs his folder to go to the
office and of course that doesn't work
it's it's the collective effort and a
chain of events that need to happen in
order to communicate the message of the
composer and what do we need to identify
I asked myself also what what if I would
sit in an audience how can I identify
something that is is an honest
and performance that is honest there are
two elements I think first as the
composition and the composition has a
desire to be communicated it comes from
the creative spirit of the composer who
thought about writing a cantata for a
specific Sunday or a piece based on a
poet that expresses the grief of the
mother mother Jesus underneath the cross
suffering seeing her dead son
so these are the basic ideas that the
composer has to communicate and then the
composer finds tools to express this in
the composition but the tools for me
needs to fit in them in a structure that
exists otherwise I can't identify I can
say a wall is green because I have seen
green walls we all agree that green is a
certain color that we can identify so
the rules have been created and that's
the nice thing about being a rock
musician on early musician being in
early music these rules have been
defined by people as probably as we
think about what is truth and beauty in
music in the Renaissance time people met
for example in Florence and they thought
what is more important in music the
music or the words and they had long
debates and composers that dared to
compose in a new style were attacked
like Claudia Monteverde when he composed
his first operas it was too wild before
the composition was merely an expression
of I would say the creator spirit of the
composer that communicated with the
universe or God however he wanted to see
it but the audience the listener was not
part of that equation and then this
group
around assembled around the father also
of galileo galilei vincenzo galilee they
tried to define new new borders for what
is important in music and they thought
that the listener was an important part
in the equation the person that listens
to the music and that music has a power
to transform human beings and that
access comes through two levels and they
define it in that and they said ma v
Raddatz AR - to move and to teach and
these are the important elements I think
coming briefly back to Andrew Lloyd
Webber
I personally think that there's nothing
bad about this music but it probably
relies too much on the emotional side of
music so it's a skillful use of certain
chord progressions knowing what they can
trigger in a listener and bath for
example combines for me ideally both
sides the complexity of his composition
and the emotional side if we just
imagine the first few bars of Obama D
for example this aria it's it's a
complex composition but it still
triggers to me it stimulates my soul
instantly not just through the intellect
that I analyze the piece and through the
analysis I gather some knowledge that
then moves me but it moves me directly
so this is probably the most direct way
to communicate with somebody's to talk
to somebody and as the body language and
the voice have ways of achieving
something like you you increase the
volume to speak louder
you can sing louder and there certain
formulas that you can use out of this
agreed toolbox that was defined at that
time and what we what I extract as truth
is only possible or I can only extract
truth in a composition if
look at it or get an idea I don't want
to say that I want to judge a
composition but I've sent something in
the composition because I can identify
these elements the tools the code that
has been agreed upon and fortunately
within all my repertoire the these rules
applies or Renaissance music Baroque
music is always based on the simple idea
if I prepare peace how would I speak it
and if my singing teacher says if you
know how to speak it you have a pretty
good idea how you would sing it so I use
the tools of rhetoric of dramatization
the narrators the orators tools there's
if we talk about historic music practice
that's what we have in the early music
scene we think a lot about how was it
done where's the source is that one true
moment
how about performed this piece and
unfortunately then some people think if
we know this we recreate this moment and
then we would have truth in this moment
but I think that's well it's like
opening an old bottle of wine maybe but
it cannot be truthful because the
musicians that play these instrument
these days live in the 21st century not
under not in the 18th century and Europe
opinion is possible that music is
truthful and not beautiful and it's
impossible that music is beautiful
without being truthful yeah absolutely
that's it's important beauty expresses
itself in two ways to me beauty to me is
a successful communication for example
of a cantata that's a beautiful thing
but the main focus for me should never
be to sing beautifully primarily that's
not it's it's to be truthful and if if
ba in the resid the first arias has de
Velde as soon dan house preach to in her
lonely house it's it's very it's
preaching with music
and it's drastic words and it's
basically accusing the whole community
in church and saying you are all evil
you're all bad and and well that cannot
be sung beautifully if I if I try to
create beautiful sounds I will miss miss
the point and that's a little bit a
danger of the countertenor voice I think
I well it's it's it's it's um being in
love with your voice and it's for for
young for young singers that can for
young singers that that can that can be
problem and you need a good teacher who
I remember of course that you have
dramatic handle areas and and you you
create beautiful sounds but it's not
really meaningful and then you need the
teachers as yeah it sounds beautiful but
it's not what it mean what is meant to
be so there's this kind of beauty and my
singing teacher for example also says
the art is to make it not sound like an
art and then that reminds me again or
what I said before about the effect and
students who work on a dramatic piece
think about how what is a gesture if
somebody's disappointed and then they
come up with something and I and I say
well what do we identify do we identify
art on stage or do we identify life on
stage if if art mirrors life and I make
a gesture like this well we've seen
people who are upset and who are
aggressive and we've seen people who are
surprised and they don't know what to
answer or something so so I don't have
to think in art terms when I do
interpretation or when I think about the
acting aspect but I need to think in
terms of life because instantly we will
if we see somebody behaving in a certain
way onstage in a certain way that we
have seen in real life we can identify
the idea but if I create operatic
gestures or I sing a Schubert song ASBO
everybody expects it
then then then then I know I turn into a
ritualized art artistic way of singing
and then I fulfill the cliche and has
also the cliche of the endless hi-c of
an opera Aria oh and then and is this
clear the cliches and we all know it and
there's a whole industry that lives of
the cliches there's yeah there's I don't
want to name any famous Dutch violinist
that work with this thing but and even
and even then I would I would not talk
badly about this because still it brings
joy to people I'm used to have hey
here's a stage first of all I'm higher
than you is not wonderful
here's a gap there's a distance and this
is how we present music and that already
suggests something and I think it
suggests the wrong idea this is this is
an idea of presenting classical music
that was invented long after the music
was composed that I sung so in a way
there's something wrong in this picture
being elevated above the audience
because it's a collective thing when I
sing I need the audience as much as the
audience wants to listen to me so so I
think and good impulse could be to bring
classical music into different places I
have no illusion about the fact that
these people who come to the yellow
lounge will buy instantly a ticket to
hear me in the concert house two weeks
later or something why because they are
afraid that this is not their kind of
classical event as the establishment
protected by music critics who if they
don't watch out saw on the branch that
they sit on because if I crush any
attempt to vitalize collect the classic
music scene if I crush any attempt in a
newspaper saying all this crappy yellow
lounge what is this terrible ah then one
day note the Phaeton will color
the cultural pages and then even classic
music critics participated in their own
sinking and I I so I think we need a
collective effort of the musicians the
promoters and the music press to try new
things and not be afraid and maybe
create a parallel music scene